Suppose that two American friends
are traveling together in Italy.
They go to see Michelangelo's "David,"
and when they finally come
face-to-face with the statue,
they both freeze dead in their tracks.
The first guy -- we'll call him Adam --
is transfixed by the beauty
of the perfect human form.
The second guy -- we'll call him Bill --
is transfixed by embarrassment, at staring
at the thing there in the center.
So here's my question for you:
Which one of these two guys was more
likely to have voted for George Bush,
which for Al Gore?
I don't need a show of hands,
because we all have the same
political stereotypes.
We all know that it's Bill.
And in this case, the stereotype
corresponds to reality.
It really is a fact that liberals
are much higher than conservatives
on a major personality trait
called openness to experience.
People who are high
in openness to experience
just crave novelty, variety,
diversity, new ideas, travel.
People low on it like things
that are familiar,
that are safe and dependable.
If you know about this trait,
you can understand a lot of puzzles
about human behavior,
like why artists are so different
from accountants.
You can predict what kinds of books
they like to read,
what kinds of places
they like to travel to
and what kinds of food they like to eat.
Once you understand this trait,
you can understand why anybody
would eat at Applebee's,
but not anybody that you know.
(Laughter)
This trait also tells us
a lot about politics.
The main researcher of this trait,
Robert McCrae,
says that "Open individuals
have an affinity
for liberal, progressive,
left-wing political views ..."
They like a society
which is open and changing,
"... whereas closed individuals prefer
conservative, traditional,
right-wing views."
This trait also tells us a lot
about the kinds of groups people join.
Here's the description
of a group I found on the web.
What kinds of people would join
"a global community ... welcoming
people from every discipline and culture,
who seek a deeper
understanding of the world,
and who hope to turn that understanding
into a better future for us all"?
This is from some guy named Ted.
Well, let's see now.
If openness predicts who becomes liberal,
and openness predicts
who becomes a TEDster,
then might we predict
that most TEDsters are liberal?
Let's find out.
I'll ask you to raise your hand,
whether you are liberal, left of center --
on social issues, primarily --
or conservative.
And I'll give a third option,
because I know there are
libertarians in the audience.
So please raise your hand --
in the simulcast rooms too.
Let's let everybody see who's here.
Please raise your hand if you'd say
that you're liberal or left of center.
Please raise your hand high right now. OK.
Please raise your hand
if you'd say you're libertarian.
OK. About two dozen.
And please raise your hand if you'd say
you are right of center or conservative.
One, two, three, four,
five -- about eight or 10.
OK.
This is a bit of a problem.
Because if our goal is to seek
a deeper understanding of the world,
our general lack of moral diversity here
is going to make it harder.
Because when people all share values,
when people all share morals,
they become a team.
And once you engage
the psychology of teams,
it shuts down open-minded thinking.
When the liberal team loses,
[United States of Canada / Jesusland]
as it did in 2004,
and as it almost did in 2000,
we comfort ourselves.
(Laughter)
We try to explain why half of America
voted for the other team.
We think they must be blinded by religion
[Post-election US map:
America / Dumbf*ckistan]
or by simple stupidity.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
So if you think that half
of America votes Republican
because they are blinded in this way,
then my message to you
is that you're trapped in a moral Matrix,
in a particular moral Matrix.
And by "the Matrix," I mean literally
the Matrix, like the movie "The Matrix."
But I'm here today to give you a choice.
You can either take the blue pill
and stick to your comforting delusions,
or you can take the red pill,
learn some moral psychology
and step outside the moral Matrix.
Now, because I know --
(Applause)
I assume that answers my question.
I was going to ask
which one you picked, but no need.
You're all high in openness to experience,
and it looks like it might even taste
good, and you're all epicures.
Anyway, let's go with the red pill,
study some moral psychology
and see where it takes us.
Let's start at the beginning:
What is morality, where does it come from?
The worst idea in all of psychology
is the idea that the mind
is a blank slate at birth.
Developmental psychology has shown
that kids come into the world
already knowing so much
about the physical and social worlds
and programmed to make it really easy
for them to learn certain things
and hard to learn others.
The best definition
of innateness I've seen,
which clarifies so many things for me,
is from the brain scientist Gary Marcus.
He says, "The initial
organization of the brain
does not depend that much on experience.
Nature provides a first draft,
which experience then revises.
'Built-in' doesn't mean unmalleable;
it means organized
in advance of experience."
OK, so what's on the first draft
of the moral mind?
To find out, my colleague Craig Joseph
and I read through the literature
on anthropology,
on culture variation in morality
and also on evolutionary psychology,
looking for matches:
What sorts of things do people
talk about across disciplines
that you find across cultures
and even species?
We found five best matches, which we call
the five foundations of morality.
The first one is harm/care.
We're all mammals here, we all have a lot
of neural and hormonal programming
that makes us really bond
with others, care for others,
feel compassion for others,
especially the weak and vulnerable.
It gives us very strong feelings
about those who cause harm.
This moral foundation
underlies about 70 percent
of the moral statements
I've heard here at TED.
The second foundation
is fairness/reciprocity.
There's actually ambiguous evidence
as to whether you find reciprocity
in other animals,
but the evidence for people
could not be clearer.
This Norman Rockwell painting
is called "The Golden Rule" --
as we heard from Karen Armstrong,
it's the foundation of many religions.
That second foundation
underlies the other 30 percent
of the moral statements
I've heard here at TED.
The third foundation is in-group/loyalty.
You do find cooperative groups
in the animal kingdom,
but these groups are always
either very small or they're all siblings.
It's only among humans that you find
very large groups of people
who are able to cooperate
and join together into groups,
but in this case, groups that are united
to fight other groups.
This probably comes from our long history
of tribal living, of tribal psychology.
And this tribal psychology
is so deeply pleasurable
that even when we don't have tribes,
we go ahead and make them,
because it's fun.
(Laughter)
Sports is to war as pornography is to sex.
We get to exercise some ancient drives.
The fourth foundation
is authority/respect.
Here you see submissive gestures
from two members
of very closely related species.
But authority in humans is not so closely
based on power and brutality
as it is in other primates.
It's based on more voluntary deference
and even elements of love, at times.
The fifth foundation is purity/sanctity.
This painting is called
"The Allegory Of Chastity,"
but purity is not just about
suppressing female sexuality.
It's about any kind of ideology,
any kind of idea
that tells you that you can attain virtue
by controlling what you do with your body
and what you put into your body.
And while the political right
may moralize sex much more,
the political left is doing
a lot of it with food.
Food is becoming extremely
moralized nowadays.
A lot of it is ideas about purity,
about what you're willing
to touch or put into your body.
I believe these
are the five best candidates
for what's written on the first draft
of the moral mind.
I think this is what we come with,
a preparedness to learn all these things.
But as my son Max grows up
in a liberal college town,
how is this first draft
going to get revised?
And how will it end up being different
from a kid born 60 miles south of us,
in Lynchburg, Virginia?
To think about culture variation,
let's try a different metaphor.
If there really are five systems
at work in the mind,
five sources of intuitions and emotions,
then we can think of the moral mind
as one of those audio equalizers
that has five channels,
where you can set it to a different
setting on every channel.
My colleagues Brian Nosek
and Jesse Graham and I
made a questionnaire, which we put up
on the web at www.YourMorals.org.
And so far, 30,000 people have taken
this questionnaire, and you can, too.
Here are the results
from about 23,000 American citizens.
On the left are the scores for liberals;
on the right, conservatives;
in the middle, moderates.
The blue line shows people's responses
on the average of all the harm questions.
So as you see, people care
about harm and care issues.
They highly endorse these sorts
of statements all across the board,
but as you also see,
liberals care about it a little more
than conservatives; the line slopes down.
Same story for fairness.
But look at the other three lines.
For liberals, the scores are very low.
They're basically saying,
"This is not morality.
In-group, authority, purity -- this has
nothing to do with morality. I reject it."
But as people get more
conservative, the values rise.
We can say liberals have
a two-channel or two-foundation morality.
Conservatives have more
of a five-foundation,
or five-channel morality.
We find this in every country we look at.
Here's the data for 1,100 Canadians.
I'll flip through a few other slides.
The UK, Australia, New Zealand,
Western Europe, Eastern Europe,
Latin America, the Middle East,
East Asia and South Asia.
Notice also that on all of these graphs,
the slope is steeper
on in-group, authority, purity,
which shows that, within any country,
the disagreement
isn't over harm and fairness.
I mean, we debate over what's fair,
but everybody agrees
that harm and fairness matter.
Moral arguments within cultures
are especially about issues
of in-group, authority, purity.
This effect is so robust, we find
it no matter how we ask the question.
In a recent study, we asked people,
suppose you're about to get a dog,
you picked a particular breed,
learned about the breed.
Suppose you learn that this particular
breed is independent-minded
and relates to its owner
as a friend and an equal.
If you're a liberal,
you say, "That's great!"
because liberals like to say,
"Fetch! Please."
(Laughter)
But if you're a conservative,
that's not so attractive.
If you're conservative and learn
that a dog's extremely loyal
to its home and family
and doesn't warm up to strangers,
for conservatives, loyalty is good;
dogs ought to be loyal.
But to a liberal,
it sounds like this dog is running
for the Republican nomination.
(Laughter)
You might say, OK, there are differences
between liberals and conservatives,
but what makes the three
other foundations moral?
Aren't they the foundations of xenophobia,
authoritarianism and puritanism?
What makes them moral?
The answer, I think, is contained in this
incredible triptych from Hieronymus Bosch,
"The Garden of Earthly Delights."
In the first panel, we see
the moment of creation.
All is ordered, all is beautiful,
all the people and animals are doing
what they're supposed to be doing,
are where they're supposed to be.
But then, given the way
of the world, things change.
We get every person doing
whatever he wants,
with every aperture of every other
person and every other animal.
Some of you might recognize
this as the '60s.
(Laughter)
But the '60s inevitably
gives way to the '70s,
where the cuttings of the apertures
hurt a little bit more.
Of course, Bosch called this hell.
So this triptych, these three panels,
portray the timeless truth
that order tends to decay.
The truth of social entropy.
But lest you think this is just
some part of the Christian imagination
where Christians have
this weird problem with pleasure,
here's the same story,
the same progression,
told in a paper that was published
in "Nature" a few years ago,
in which Ernst Fehr and Simon Gächter
had people play a commons dilemma,
a game in which you give people money,
and then, on each round of the game,
they can put money into a common pot,
then the experimenter
doubles what's there,
and then it's all divided
among the players.
So it's a nice analog
for all sorts of environmental issues,
where we're asking people
to make a sacrifice
and they don't really benefit
from their own sacrifice.
You really want everybody
else to sacrifice,
but everybody has
a temptation to free ride.
What happens is that, at first,
people start off reasonably cooperative.
This is all played anonymously.
On the first round, people give
about half of the money that they can.
But they quickly see
other people aren't doing so much.
"I don't want to be a sucker.
I won't cooperate."
So cooperation quickly decays
from reasonably good
down to close to zero.
But then -- and here's the trick --
Fehr and Gächter,
on the seventh round, told people,
"You know what? New rule.
If you want to give some of your own money
to punish people who aren't contributing,
you can do that."
And as soon as people heard
about the punishment issue going on,
cooperation shoots up.
It shoots up and it keeps going up.
Lots of research shows that to solve
cooperative problems, it really helps.
It's not enough to appeal
to people's good motives.
It helps to have some sort of punishment.
Even if it's just shame
or embarrassment or gossip,
you need some sort of punishment
to bring people, when they're in large
groups, to cooperate.
There's even some recent research
suggesting that religion --
priming God, making
people think about God --
often, in some situations, leads to more
cooperative, more pro-social behavior.
Some people think
that religion is an adaptation
evolved both by cultural
and biological evolution
to make groups to cohere,
in part for the purpose
of trusting each other
and being more effective
at competing with other groups.
That's probably right,
although this is a controversial issue.
But I'm particularly interested
in religion and the origin of religion
and in what it does to us and for us,
because I think the greatest wonder
in the world is not the Grand Canyon.
The Grand Canyon is really simple --
a lot of rock and a lot of water
and wind and a lot of time,
and you get the Grand Canyon.
It's not that complicated.
This is what's complicated:
that people lived in places like the Grand
Canyon, cooperating with each other,
or on the savannahs of Africa
or the frozen shores of Alaska.
And some of these villages
grew into the mighty cities of Babylon
and Rome and Tenochtitlan.
How did this happen?
It's an absolute miracle, much harder
to explain than the Grand Canyon.
The answer, I think, is that they used
every tool in the toolbox.
It took all of our moral psychology
to create these cooperative groups.
Yes, you need to be concerned about harm,
you need a psychology of justice.
But it helps to organize a group
if you have subgroups,
and if those subgroups
have some internal structure,
and if you have some ideology
that tells people
to suppress their carnality --
to pursue higher, nobler ends.
Now we get to the crux of the disagreement
between liberals and conservatives:
liberals reject
three of these foundations.
They say, "Let's celebrate diversity,
not common in-group membership,"
and, "Let's question authority,"
and, "Keep your laws off my body."
Liberals have very noble
motives for doing this.
Traditional authority and morality
can be quite repressive and restrictive
to those at the bottom, to women,
to people who don't fit in.
Liberals speak for the weak and oppressed.
They want change and justice,
even at the risk of chaos.
This shirt says, "Stop bitching,
start a revolution."
If you're high in openness to experience,
revolution is good; it's change, it's fun.
Conservatives, on the other hand,
speak for institutions and traditions.
They want order, even at some cost,
to those at the bottom.
The great conservative insight
is that order is really hard to achieve.
It's precious,
and it's really easy to lose.
So as Edmund Burke said,
"The restraints on men,
as well as their liberties,
are to be reckoned among their rights."
This was after the chaos
of the French Revolution.
Once you see that liberals
and conservatives
both have something to contribute,
that they form a balance
on change versus stability,
then I think the way is open
to step outside the moral Matrix.
This is the great insight
that all the Asian religions
have attained.
Think about yin and yang.
Yin and yang aren't enemies;
they don't hate each other.
Yin and yang are both necessary,
like night and day,
for the functioning of the world.
You find the same thing in Hinduism.
There are many high gods in Hinduism.
Two of them are Vishnu, the preserver,
and Shiva, the destroyer.
This image, actually,
is both of those gods
sharing the same body.
You have the markings
of Vishnu on the left,
so we could think of Vishnu
as the conservative god.
You have the markings of Shiva
on the right -- Shiva's the liberal god.
And they work together.
You find the same thing in Buddhism.
These two stanzas contain,
I think, the deepest insights
that have ever been attained
into moral psychology.
From the Zen master Sēngcàn:
"If you want the truth to stand clear
before you, never be 'for' or 'against.'
The struggle between 'for' and 'against'
is the mind's worst disease."
Unfortunately, it's a disease
that has been caught
by many of the world's leaders.
But before you feel
superior to George Bush,
before you throw a stone, ask yourself:
Do you accept this?
Do you accept stepping out
of the battle of good and evil?
Can you be not for or against anything?
So what's the point? What should you do?
Well, if you take the greatest insights
from ancient Asian
philosophies and religions
and combine them with the latest
research on moral psychology,
I think you come to these conclusions:
that our righteous minds
were designed by evolution
to unite us into teams,
to divide us against other teams
and then to blind us to the truth.
So what should you do?
Am I telling you to not strive?
Am I telling you to embrace
Sēngcàn and stop,
stop with the struggle of for and against?
No, absolutely not. I'm not saying that.
This is an amazing group of people
who are doing so much,
using so much of their talent,
their brilliance,
their energy, their money,
to make the world a better place,
to fight wrongs,
to solve problems.
But as we learned from Samantha Power
in her story about Sérgio Vieira de Mello,
you can't just go charging in,
saying, "You're wrong, and I'm right,"
because, as we just heard,
everybody thinks they are right.
A lot of the problems we have to solve
are problems that require us
to change other people.
And if you want to change other people,
a much better way to do it
is to first understand who we are --
understand our moral psychology,
understand that we all
think we're right --
and then step out,
even if it's just for a moment,
step out -- check in with Sēngcàn.
Step out of the moral Matrix,
just try to see it
as a struggle playing out,
in which everybody thinks they're right,
and even if you disagree with them,
everybody has some reasons
for what they're doing.
Step out.
And if you do that, that's the essential
move to cultivate moral humility,
to get yourself out
of this self-righteousness,
which is the normal human condition.
Think about the Dalai Lama.
Think about the enormous
moral authority of the Dalai Lama.
It comes from his moral humility.
So I think the point --
the point of my talk
and, I think, the point of TED --
is that this is a group
that is passionately engaged
in the pursuit of changing
the world for the better.
People here are passionately engaged
in trying to make
the world a better place.
But there is also a passionate
commitment to the truth.
And so I think the answer is to use
that passionate commitment to the truth
to try to turn it
into a better future for us all.
Thank you.
(Applause)